kastlevania may be new to Netflix but to
video game fans Castlevania is a 30 year
old series that's been a mainstay of
gaming since Nintendo entertainment
systems heyday while the Netflix show
isn't directly based on one game in
particular it's loosely based on
Castlevania 3 Dracula's curse released
in the u.s. in 1990 for the NES but
paying close attention to the action and
set pieces reveals the cartoon creators
actually pulled from a lot of different
games in the series if you're a 10 of
the most notable references we found
while watching the show there are
probably a few that we missed so join
the conversation and drop any references
you noticed into the comments if you
liked this video be sure to subscribe to
GameSpot and GameSpot universe for the
latest in gaming and entertainment
number one Dracula teleports with a
pillar of fire after learning that his
wife was killed for witchcraft in
episode 1 Dracula teleports from their
humble homestead back to the magical
castle via a pillar of fire this is a
technique used by Dracula and a few of
the Castlevania games most notably
during the final boss battle in super
Castlevania 4 on the Super Nintendo and
during the prologue of Playstations
Castlevania Symphony of the Night which
was a retelling of the final battle from
Castlevania Rondo of blood number 2
fountain overflowing with blood you have
to give Netflix credit for allowing the
Castlevania cartoon to feature as much
brutality and violence as it does
seriously it's incredibly gruesome
sometimes in one notable seen when
Dracula's hell spawn rise to kill the
citizens of Wallachia as punishment for
killing his wife Lesa we see a city
drenched in blood in human remains
though it may be just a coincidence a
fountain overflowing with blood can also
be seen and astute Castlevania fans may
remember seeing a similar fountain in
the fifth stage of Castlevania
bloodlines on the Sega Genesis 3 Trevor
bares a scar over his left eye Trevor
the lead character of the Netflix show
made his debut back in Castlevania 3
Dracula's curse that game made with low
res graphics and a limited color palette
made it difficult to discern Trevor's
appearance beyond the colour of his
clothes in Castlevania curse of darkness
Trevor reappears and this time we get a
better look at his facial features
including a scar across his left eye a
scar that's almost identical to
the one seen on Trevor's face in the
show for Trevor faces off with a cyclops
when Trevor fights the Cyclops to rescue
sefa during the show it's a direct
reference to a boss battle in
Castlevania 3 Dracula's curse where
Trevor fights the same creature in an
environment littered with petrified
humans five cephas masqueraded as a man
before her true identity is revealed
sefa is a female but when we first see
her in the show she's dressed in men's
garb making Trevor's revelation that
she's a woman come as a surprise you
seekers wouldn't do that
what dress the girls like boys this is
yet another callback to Castlevania 3 in
the manual for that game sefa was
referred to as he and her face was
obscured in the accompanying character
portrait but at the end of the game
Seifer removes her hood during the
closing credits and her long hair gives
away her true identity 6 trevor loses
his cape when he gets down to business
for a large portion of the 4 episode
Netflix show Trevor is seen wearing a
cape but once it's up to him to step up
against evil he purposefully sheds his
cape
hello again Castlevania 3 where Trevor
goes capless once the action begins 7
jumping across the massive gear works
when Trevor and sefa fall beneath the
streets of Wallachia they quickly end up
traversing a massive room housing big
turning gears similar gears are often
featured within Castlevania games clock
towers and once again Castlevania 3
stands out as the origin of the
tradition 8 trevor swings across
platforms using his whip shortly after
Trevor and sefa across the
aforementioned gears Trevor uses his
whip to swing from one platform to
another and this is a technique used in
a few of the Castlevania games most
notably though in super Castlevania 4
number 9
Alec arts teleportation ability looks
eerily familiar
Alucard plays a major role in the final
episode of the Netflix show during a
battle with Trevor he teleports out of
harm's way leaving a ghostly after image
behind it's not a direct copy of his
movements and Symphony of the Night but
it's in that game where he adopts the
habit of quickly shifting through space
in a similar
fashioned 10 alec cards coat is directly
modeled after his coat and symphony of
the night after Alucard test Trevor and
sefa in combat he puts on a coat that is
clearly styled after his uniform and
symphony of the night that's all the
references that we found guys if you can
find any more let us know in the
comments below as always for more games
stuff keep it locked on GameSpot and if
you guys want to check out some more
entertainment content go over to
GameSpot universe we have a giveaway
right now for an exclusive 2017
comic-con t-shirt you have to watch a
little bit of our content but I mean
it's kind of worth it